let's talk about buffer capacity
buffer capacity is a property of a
buffer
and
it tells you how much
acid or base you can add before the ph
starts changing
basically as
your buffer capacity goes up which i'm
going to abbreviate bc as your buffer
capacity goes up
you can
add
more
of your acid or base
before the ph starts changing a lot
that might seem like a pretty vague and
qualitative definition so let's go
through an example to see
what that might look like exactly
the example we're going to look at is
going to be using an acetic acid buffer
so acetic acid is ch3cooh
and we're going to abbreviate that in
this talk using ha
and this is an nucleus solution
and that is reversibly
reacting
to form h plus
ion
and
c
h3
cool minus or acetate
and so we're going to abbreviate acetate
in this talk as a minus
some more information about this
particular buffer
acetic acid the ka
is equal to
1.8 times 10 to the minus 5
and if we take the negative log of that
that will give us the pka which is also
useful
and the pka of acetic acid is 4.74
so that'll tell us a lot about the
behavior of this buffer
and the last thing we need to know for
predicting the behavior of our buffer
is
what the ratio is between our h a and a
minus
so
we're going to be looking
at a buffer where
a minus
over h a this ratio
is equal to
1.82
based on this ratio we can calculate the
ph
so the initial ph
of our buffer before we do anything to
it before we add any acid or we add any
base
the initial ph of our buffer we can
calculate using the
henderson-hasselbalch equation
and so that equation tells us that ph is
equal to pka
plus log of a minus concentration
or acetate over acetic acid
concentration
and if you're not
100 confident with using this equation
or you want to know where it comes from
we actually have separate videos on that
so i would recommend checking those out
in this equation or sorry in this video
we're just going to use this equation as
is
so if we plug in our values here we get
that the initial pka is equal to
4.74
our pka
plus log of
1.82 which is our ratio of a minus over
h a
so then we know that our initial ph is
equal to
5.00
what we're going to do next is we're
going to look at
two different buffers
and both of them are going to be made
with acetic acid
and
with acetate
and we're going to call them buffer one
and buffer two
so buffer one
has a ratio
of a minus nha that is 1.82
so the ph is going to be 5
and the a minus concentration
before we do anything to it before we
add anything is 0.90 molar
and the ha concentration
is going to be 0.49 molar
and our second buffer that we're going
to compare it to
we will call
buffer
and buffer 2
also has the same ratio of acid to base
except this time
both concentrations are going to be 10
times smaller than buffer one so our a
minus concentration is 0.09
0 molar
and our
acetic acid concentration is 0.049
molar
and what we're going to do here is we're
going to see what happens to the ph of
both of these so they both start out
with a ph of 5 but how much should they
change
when we add
we're going to
add
0.04
moles of a strong base sodium hydroxide
to one liter buffer
so when you do that
well it's a buffer we know that it's
going to resist the ph change but what
exactly is happening what's the reaction
that goes on when you add this in
so when you add your strong base
which is going to dissociate to form oh
minus
it's going to react with the acid in
your buffer
so our acid is
ch3cooh
and we always assume
that a strong base is going to reverse
uh sorry it's going to react
irreversibly so one-sided arrow with a
weak acid
so what happens is this proton
is going to react with oh minus and
we're going to get h2o or water
and we're going to make
ch3coo
minus
so that's our base
and so we can see that the hydroxide is
going to react one to one with our weak
acid and it's going to produce one
equivalent of our base so now we can use
this information to calculate what
happens to our buffer when we add 0.04
moles of sodium hydroxide
what's going to happen is it's going to
react with our acid
which means the concentration of the
acetic acid is going to go down by 0.04
molar
our new concentration after it's reacted
is going to be
0.45 molar
sorry i tried to do that in my head
and
what happens to our concentration of the
base
remember that when the acid reacts with
sodium hydroxide we actually make more
base
so we
have to adjust
the concentration of a minus upward it
actually makes
.04 molar
acetate when this reaction happens so
our new concentration of our acetate ion
is
0.94 molar
so if these are our final concentrations
we can now plug them plug them back in
to the henderson-hasselblack equation to
get the ph
so the ph of buffer one
i'll put a little subscript one
is going to be
4.74 the pka
plus
log of 0.94
molar
divided by 0.45 molar
and if we plug that into our calculator
we get that the ph after we add that
hydroxide is 5.06 so it's a little bit
higher it went up by 0.06
that makes sense um we do imagine it
would be higher
if you add base it becomes more basic
and the ph should go up but it didn't
change a whole lot because
it's a buffer
now let's compare that with what happens
to buffer two
we add 0.04 mol sodium hydroxide to
buffer two our acetic acid concentration
is going to go down by 0.04 molar
so our new concentration of ha is .009
molar by the same
reaction our base concentration is going
to go up
since when the acid reacts it makes more
conjugate base
so we're going to have to add
0.04 molar to a minus concentration
and so the new concentration is going to
be 0.13 molar
and we can plug those
concentrations into the
henderson-hasselbalch equation and we
get that ph
of our buffer 2
is equal to 4.74
rpka
plus 0 oops plus log
of
0.13 molar divided by
0.009
molar
and so that would be if we plug this
into our calculator this is equal to
1.16 so if we add that together with our
pka we get that the new ph is
5.90 molar
so the ph changed a whole lot more for
buffer two than for buffer one um the ph
went up by point nine instead of by .06
so if we're comparing the buffer
capacities of both of these buffers we
would say that buffer one
well
the buffer changes less when you add the
same amount of asset or base so buffer
one has the higher buffer capacity
since you don't want
these concentrations a minus and h a to
be too low the general rule of thumb is
that you want
your concentrations of h a
and a minus
between
0.10 molar
and
and 1.0 molar
and by following that rule of thumb you
can make a buffer where you don't have
to worry too much
about adding too much acid or base
before your ph changes since that's
usually why you're making a buffer in
the first place